how many feature scripts have you
written oh gosh let me think uh feature
skips we have written one
two i have to count probably seven or
eight feature scripts and then
probably oh two or three
television or teleplay scripts you know
shorter like pilots or
um
you know our podcast script or um
so so probably about a dozen
scripts in total
and then within those dozen completed
scripts
you know certainly we have a you know a
giant board with all of our ideas and
then we have a lot of treatments for
things that we've written and we've
written
a lot of um
you know we've written a lot of pitch
decks for a lot of our projects and
we've written a lot of series bibles or
series pitches for a lot of our
television projects
so yeah a lot of a lot of writing a lot
of writing but yeah we think i would say
about a dozen
probably feature screenplays
and when you first started writing these
features who would you send them to
for reading
you know when we first started writing
features i think
um
there was probably probably about
there was there was two major things we
would do i guess i would say or
i think would recommend for people i
mean certainly like your friends
um
if if you have friends in the industry
fantastic that's great send them to
those friends
and even if you don't have friends in
the industry still anybody who's willing
to read it i would say send it to them
because it can it can take people a
while to read a screenplay and get back
to you
but also i think what was really helpful
for us in the early days is
you can find there's there's many of
them online the you know there are
screenwriting services or screenwriting
consultancy agencies and um
screenwriting contests things like that
but i think what was really helpful for
us and we first started we would do a
lot of those
because i think what's helpful is the
turnaround time as i said like you can
of course and and i recommend getting
the scripts to your friends and
family and people like that or people in
the industry if you know it but of
course it can really take people a while
to
read a screenplay
think about it get back to you you know
we're all busy everybody's
you know doing something or doing their
job or they've got their own scripts
so i think a big benefit
in the early days for us of sending it
to those screenwriting like coverage
places or consulting agencies was just
the turnaround time you were able to get
it in
you know sometimes it's it's quick
sometimes it's you know 72 hours or a
week or two weeks
and i think especially when you're
at least for us when you're just
starting out having that
instant feedback or
or
quick turnaround feedback was really
helpful because
we could
keep up the momentum of our script you
know what i mean like when you're
writing it like
being able to
get notes
quickly would help us just get back into
a draft and really
either keep on shaping it or keep
adjusting things that maybe didn't work
so well or and maybe if we did hear that
they were working well
you know we would we would leave them
and i think another benefit
to sending it to those agencies you know
those screenwriting competitions or
consulting consulting agencies
was
you know you're just doing it blind like
if you send it to
your family or your friends they know
you maybe perhaps they even know the
story of the screenplay
and when you send it to those people
it's just you know it's anonymous um
[Music]
so it's like i think um they can give
you sometimes
you know brutal feedback or honest
feedback about what's really working or
what's not working and they're not
necessarily as concerned about you know
your feelings or
or how you know the story or you know
they don't necessarily know that it was
maybe something that happened to you or
something from your past or whatever it
is they really just focus on that script
so i i would suggest that and i think
that's a really
um helpful thing to do and i know that
helped us a lot in the beginning
do you think hollywood's closed off
i don't think hollywood's closed off i
think
i think um
you know again because i've been doing
this for so long
i think hollywood
and i've been in the business 25 years
25 or 20 plus years
you know i think it's more open now than
probably i've ever seen it before
because of
social media
i think you know i i know social media
is like a double-edged sword like
you know you have outrage over
game of thrones episodes but you can
also like really i've seen a lot of
people like really legitimately
advance
their careers as actors or screenwriters
or directors whatever it is because
they're
they're just releasing stuff online
they're able to find an audience and
then use that to kind of
you know uh
catapult themselves into something else
or to find a representation as a as a
writer or as an actor director
and i think another thing
actually is kind of cool about
you know hollywood becoming more open
and
with social media too
you know you have things like
crowdfunding that never existed before
and i've you know we've crowdfunded
ourselves
and it's just been like an amazing
resource and we were able to do so much
more for our films because we did have
we were able to generate those funds
so no i i don't think hollywood is
closed off i think that this is probably
the most open
i've ever seen it
are you okay if the two of you never get
a feature film made will you be okay
with shorts and
little you know web series and things
like that
no
to answer your question
i we are really always striving for that
feature film that is really
important to us you know important to me
and important to sarah my partner
um
you know we we love film and we love
television and we've made a lot of
really wonderful short films films that
we're really proud of and we're gonna
continue making them we're gonna
continue writing scripts and making
webisodes and podcasts but there's one
thing that we really haven't
fully tackled yet and i i don't think we
can really
cross that off cross our list you know
our bucket list so to speak our
filmmaking bucket list until we hit the
future and so that's something we're
still
pushing towards and i think um you know
we've gotten close many many times and
obviously the
the pandemic that we've all just went
through and that we're starting to come
out of now is sort of through everybody
for a for a loop um
i know a lot of filmmaker friends and
actor friends and i know a lot of
people's
projects were sort of put on hold some
people were able to continue working but
but i think um
yeah i think that made a lot of people
lose momentum so i think um now that
everything's back i think we're ready to
to you know throw our hat in the ring
again and go after the feature next
and are you too
cautious in in terms of you want to do
it right like you know i see people do
amazing crowdfunding campaigns but then
it turns out oh we didn't raise enough
we've got to go back
and i know that's difficult yeah to
and it happens it
it happens with everything in life
it's this amount the time i couldn't i
couldn't even tell you
how many stories i've seen about people
making features
that have taken them years literally
years to make
one feature where they you know
shoot uh something and then a year later
come back and shoot something else and
these aren't documentary features where
you can you know these are narrative
feature films where you're
using the same actors for you know
sometimes years at a time
i've heard so many stories like that
um and and so yeah we are a little bit
cautious and the films that sarah
and i enjoy making and the things we
like to do are kind of high concept a
little bit complex or a little bit
complicated there's a lot of usually
there's a lot of moving parts in our
short films and
in in our webisodes and in things like
that
so
we are cautious i don't think we're
ready
we're i don't think we're going to
jump into a feature until we kind of
um
feel like we have
you know there's you're never going to
feel
completely comfortable you're always no
matter what you do i think
making films you're always
there there's always a an unknown you
know always always and there's always
going to be a million problems every day
um
but yeah we are we are being a little
bit cautious about
exactly how we're going to jump into a
future
but i i'm hoping that you know from the
experiences we've had on
all of our shorts and just with all of
the festivals we've been to
you know i i think we can kind of see
uh
a little more of of where it could go
wrong
um
and so we're it's it's really going to
be about trying to
um
kind of
course correct ahead of time so it
doesn't go wrong
while we're in the moment
do you have a date a target date like
the feature will be finished you know we
i we don't have a target date of when
we're trying to make a feature
and i feel like
at least for me personally i've kind of
tried to get over that idea that i need
to have it done at a certain time or i
need to be a
certain age or i need to um
you know x y and z needs to fall into
place before i can go out and do it i'm
trying not to let myself
get distracted by that
but
i i do want to focus first on making it
excellent and also making it
realistic
something that we can accomplish and
accomplish well
you know set out to do and really
execute it at a very high high level
but you know for whatever budget we're
able to
um to to get or to finance it for i
guess if that makes sense like i want to
make sure like we're we're being
realistic
um
and that we're just gonna we're really
going to deliver
that so that's more important to
to me and to us than to put a ticking
clock on it
you